[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
et au sénat et nous accueillons
aujourd'hui avec elsa mandingue à 20 la
députée yaël boon peavey bonjour bonjour
vous êtes président de la commission des
lois à l'assemblée nationale et c'est
elsa qui vous présente
il ya une brune pide bonjour donc en
2017 vous êtes élue députée la
république en marche vous raflez la
circonscription de l'indéboulonnable
jacques myard dans les yvelines et vous
êtes un peu ce que la république en
marche je veux montrer un vous êtes une
femme vous n'aviez quasiment pas fait de
politique avant à part un rapide passage
au parti socialiste quand vous viviez en
asie vous ne vous arrêtez pas là vous
prenez la surprise générale la tête de
la très puissante commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale chez les
oppositions mais aussi dans votre propre
quand on est plutôt allez soyons sympas
dubitatif quant à votre nomination
mais vous tenez vous affrontez les
textes les moments sensibles difficile à
loisy l'immigration la commission
benalla c'est votre commission qui a sur
son bureau tous les textes sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
quand vous y aviez pris votre post il y
a trois ans et demi est ce que vous vous
attendiez madam michelle braun privé à
gérer tout ça non je m'y attendais pas
mais c'est je vais être franche
un bonheur de tous les instants parce
que c'est passionnant parce qu'on se
sent utile et que la commission des lois
ce n'est pas philippe bas qui me
démentira c'est la plus belle commission
dans notre parlement
donc c'est vraiment pour moi un honneur
et une chance incroyable de la présider
mais il ya beaucoup de sujets qui vous
concerne cette semaine voici les sujets
que nous allons aborder lors de cette
émission les parlementaires amené à se
prononcer sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire
le décret pris par le gouvernement le
rétabli pour quatre semaines mais
l'exécutif entend le prolonger jusqu'au
16 février 2021
la situation est grave selon le premier
ministre castex désormais ce sont 46
millions de français qui sont soumis au
couvre feu de 21 heures à 6 heures
quelles réponses apportées après
l'assassinât de sa mère pattie à
conflans sainte honorine auditionné au
sénat gérald darmanin met en garde face
à un risque d'attentât toujours très
élevé des réseaux sociaux pointé du
doigt ils ont incontestablement joué un
rôle dans l'engrenage qui a précédé
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit faut-il
légiférer le gouvernement essaye de
trouver de nouvelles pistes et on
commence par l'état d'urgence sanitaire
débattu à l'assemblée depuis samedi 17
octobre la france est à nouveau en état
d'urgence sanitaire un simple décret a
suffi pour l'instaurer jusqu'au 16
novembre mais le gouvernement veut aller
plus loin il lui faut donc l'aval du
parlement les discussions commençaient à
l'assemblée résumé des débats en
commission avec stéphanie des pierres le
gouvernement veut faire voter l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 16 février
puis instaurer une période de transition
jusqu'au 1er avril soit plus de cinq
mois sous un régime d'exception à droite
comme à gauche on estime que c'est trop
long donner des moyens c'est une chose
sur une bonne base juridique
oui mais deux sur une durée limitée l'à
une fois de plus et c'est la même
antienne depuis le début parce que c'est
vraiment ce que nous croyons nous nous
sentons privé le parlement privé d'une
partie de son action avec un quasi blanc
ça jusqu'au 1er avril
est ce qu'il n'ya pas moyen mais si le
ministre de d'avoir des rendez vous plus
régulier avec les parlementaires pour
faire le point de la situation
il ya bien sûr la question du rôle du
parlement mais derrière la question du
rôle du parlement il ya la question de
l'adhésion de la population aux mesures
prises or nous constatons que l'adhésion
de la population challenger que le temps
passe et de plus en plus faible selon le
gouvernement le caractère imprévisible
de l'épidémie justifie cette
réactivation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire pour plusieurs mois on va pas
rouvrir quand on sortira l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
on sera pas en état dans notre pays 2
ouvrir de façon sèche l'ensemble de
discothèque dans toutes les métropoles
de france pour citer cet exemple là et
donc on anticipe cette sortie pourquoi
le 16 février pas une autre date
parce que si on avait dû choisir une
autre date elle aurait été sans doute
plus lointaine de manière à ne pas pour
les mêmes raisons se retrouver au coeur
de l'hiver avec la nécessité de
réentendre un nouveau projet de loi
adobe pour pouvoir prolonger les mesures
après l'assemblée le projet de loi doit
être validé au sénat en fin de semaine
prochaine
y a le profil d'un état d'urgence qui va
jusqu'au 16 février pour les oppositions
c'est trop et ce qu'on ne pouvait pas
choisir une date un peu plus en avant
alors il ya une discussion sur la date
et vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
reportage
il faut savoir à quelle logique on obéit
et c'est un petit peu la même logique
que celle de la loi de 1955 sur l'état
d'urgence
nous avions décidé en mars quand nous
avons créé ce régime de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire il n'existait pas à vraiment
dans notre droit nous avions dit le
gouvernement doit pouvoir le décréter
très rapidement donc par un décret et au
bout d'un mois
il faut qu'il passe devant le parlement
et le parlement pourra le projet pour
une durée qu'il définit et souvenez-vous
sur l'état d'urgence classique entre
2015 et 2017 les prorogations parfois
été trois mois parfois de quatre parfois
même de six voire huit mois et donc là
on est exactement dans la même situation
on a prorogé à plusieurs reprises c'est
la cinquième fois que nous allons
examiner un texte sur l'état d'urgence
l'idée c'est de le proroger jusqu'en
février et d'organiser également la
sortie tout cela dans le même texte
je voudrais juste rajouter j'ai fait le
compte à l'assemblée nationale on est à
80 heures de débats parlementaires sur
l'état d'urgence donc c'est extrêmement
important que le parlement délibère ce
n'est pas juste à la main du
gouvernement
mais après ça ne sert à rien de
délibérer tous les mois sur le sujet
sachant la longueur des débats et la
longueur de la navette parlementaire
albi vs que tout de même ces limitations
à nos libertés dans la durée elle vous
inquiète vous l'avez dit c'est la 5ème
prorogation est ce qu'on va vers l'état
d'urgence permanent pas du tout et
justement c'est pour ça que l'on vient
devant le parlement on en discute et
nous on autorise le gouvernement pour
une certaine durée à utiliser un certain
nombre de pouvoirs
compte tenu d'une situation sanitaire
exceptionnel donc tout cela est
extrêmement un cadré est extrêmement bas
lisez donc ça n'a rien de permanent
en revanche il est impératif et tout le
monde
comprendre aujourd'hui qu une situation
sanitaire données il nous faut une
réponse juridique qui ont résonné même
nos libertés face à des impératifs de
sécurité sanitaire on l'entend ça peut
bien ce qu'il a fait c'est ça m'a
inquiété mais vous savez à l'assemblée
nationale dans l'hémicycle il ya deux
statues une qui représente l'ordre
public et une qui représente la liberté
et tous les textes toutes les actions
doivent tenir compte de ces deux
impératifs là et là on a la scène
sécurité sanitaire de nos concitoyens
c'est notre priorité et nos libertés et
il faut concilier les deux votre
commission des lois a créé une mission
d'information sur ce régime juridique il
est quand même fragile juridiquement ce
cadre d'état d'urgence sanitaire alors
il faut encore une fois se reporter à ce
qui s'est passé en mars nous avions
décidé une chose essentielle s'était
créé un régime d'urgence sanitaire tout
de suite le gouvernement n'avait besoin
pour protéger nos concitoyens et en même
temps c'était dit mais on ne peut pas
durablement installé un régime justement
d'exception dans notre droit aussi
rapidement donc il faudra prendre le
temps et on avait mis une clause
extinction donc au 31 mars 2021 le
régime d'état d'urgence sanitaire
n'existera plus dans notre droit est
donc là moi ce que j'ai souhaité à la
commission des lois c'est que nous
puissions travailler dans la durée
pouvoir auditionner des
constitutionnalistes regard faire du
droit comparé et avoir un petit retour
d'expérience le mettre dans la loi cette
possibilité de l'état d'urgence et alors
ça n'est pas éventuellement c'est sûr
parce que on aura besoin de pouvoir
actionner à ce régime juridique lorsque
l'on laisse la place à une situation
sanitaire exceptionnelle alors le projet
de loi habilite aussi à nouveau le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
est ce que le parlement risque une
nouvelle fois d'être un petit peu
escamoté dans la crise le sénat a
d'ailleurs créé lui une délégation qui
est spécialement là pour contrôler
l'application des lois par ordonnance si
on entend bien ses inquiétudes
alors oui tout à fait il faut que le
parlement lorsque non habilite le
gouvernement continue à effectuer son
contrôle donc nous à la commission des
lois ont publié sur notre site
l'ensemble des ordonnances leur contenu
la date du projet doit de prorogation il
est extrêmement important d'effectuer le
suivi ce n'est pas du tout un blanc
simple parlement
n'a pas été un peu réduit à un rôle de
spectateur dans cette crise qu'on a vécu
on a entendu un des parlementaires qui
l'ont regretté mais il le regrette mais
moi ça c'est quelque chose que je
conteste absolument
encore une fois hier nous étions en
commission des lois nous avons
auditionné le ministre de la santé le
ministre de l'intérieur les débats se
sont tenus sans aucune limitation donc
le parlement existe après il existe
différemment mais les institutions
fonctionnent et c'est la solidité de
notre vème république
rapidement sur la situation sanitaire 46
millions de français sous couvre-feu est
ce que c'est le dernier avertissement
avant un confinement
alors il faut l'espérer moi ce que je
vois c'est que et ce que j'entends c'est
qu'il ya une ex une augmentation
exponentielle des contaminations en ce
moment et que la seule façon de le
freiner c'est d'avoir des mesures très
fortes
donc ces mesures fortes c'est le
couvre-feu qui doit produire ses effets
entre 15 et 18 jours après son démarrage
est donc là il faudra réévaluer la
situation mais pour voir si
effectivement si ça a marché mais on
pourra rester sur ce niveau là de sûreté
si ça ne marchait pas il faudra
envisager de faire plus une toute
dernière question sur le report des
élections régionales et départementales
on entend les oppositions mais qui
s'opposent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous y êtes
favorable ce qu'il ya aussi des arrière
pensées politiques dans tout cela
alors là on avait bien entendu un canton
il s'agit de reporter les municipales il
ya le jour du vote et il y à la campagne
hélas ce qui est en question c'est plus
la campagne que le jour du vote le jour
du vote on sait faire avec les mesures
barrières les masques les isoloirs et à
l'ailé venu ça on sait faire mais en
revanche une campagne à distance en
réunion publique sont rachetés et son
marché
ça marche pas bien donc il faudrait
regarder très vite et c'est ce que va
faire le président de bray avec
l'ensemble des partis politiques
mais s'agissant d'un enjeu démocratique
il est important de consulter tout le
monde et de concerter tout le monde donc
c'est ce qui est fait on verra dans un
mois ce qui est sûr c'est que le
parlement sera saisi d'un projet de loi
s'il fallait les reporter et que là le
débat démocratique aura lieu très
de façon très complète et c'est vraiment
heureux encore une fois ce sont des
enjeux démocratiques donc le parlement
doit se prononcer il ya les brawn qui
viennent à la menace sanitaire d'un côté
la menace terroriste re de l'autre avec
l'assassinât du professeur samuel pâti à
conflans sainte honorine
c'est le deuxième thème de notre
émission et place d'abord à l'émotion
avec dans les images de l'hommage
national qui s'est tenu un mercredi dans
la cour de la sorbonne ce lieu
symbolisant la connaissance l'esprit des
lumières
le président de la république a conclu
la cérémonie par un discours consacré à
sa mère pattie et s'adressant même à lui
regarde et nous continuerons oui ce
combat pour la liberté et pour la raison
donc vous êtes désormais le visage parce
que nous vous le devons parce que
nous nous le devons parce qu'en france
professeur les lumières ne s'éteignent
jamais yaël boon peavey vous est aussi
député des yvelines c'est dans les
yvelines que s'est produit le terrible
drame de conflans sainte honorine cet
attentat qu'avez vous ressenti mercredi
lors de cet hommage rendu par la nation
c'est un hommage très digne qui nous a
tous vraiment c'était poignant
moi j'y pensais en fait et j'ai écrit
tout de suite quand suis rentré chez moi
à ma maîtresse de cp
parce que on a tous un maître une
maîtresse qui nous a qui nous a marqués
et en fait ça à travers sa nouvelle
bâtisse et tous les enseignants qui nous
ouvre au monde qui font ce que l'on est
auquel tout le monde a pensé je pense
que voilà c'est important de leur rendre
hommage et lui rendre hommage bien sûr
alors on va aussi s'intéresser bien sûr
aux conséquences aux questions
qu'opposer bien cet attentat jean michel
blanquer gérald darmanin ont expliqué
jeudi au sénat ce qui a mené à ce
terrible assassinat le ministre de
l'intérieur alerte sur un risque
d'attentats toujours très élevé jérôme
rallier au lendemain de l'hommage
national à samuel pâtit
place aux propositions du gouvernement
pour répondre à cet assassinat
auditionné au sénat avec jean michel
blanquer air gérald darmanin a concédé
faire face à une forme nouvelle de
menaces c'est un attentat d'un nouveau
genre
malgré tout qui est arrivé pour la
première fois ce qui relève de
l'islamisme politique est en lien direct
avec un attentat terroriste dans la
panoplie que le ministère de l'intérieur
propose la création d'un délit pour
diffusion d'informations personnelles
mais aussi la volonté de mieux lutter
contre des associations en instaurant
une sanction intermédiaire entre la
dissolution et le laissait faire
suspendre telle ou telle association en
attendant que dirigeant de sap hilal que
des excuses soient donnés qu'à sa tombe
de deux faits soit sa portée après tout
la structure n'est pas forcément
responsable toujours mais entre la
dissolution est rien pour l'instant il
n'y a que les procédures pénales qui met
parfois beaucoup de temps
une suspension des associations qui
avait été proposé par
commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur la
radicalisation islamiste
même si pour le président de la
commission des lois du sénat la
rédaction d'une telle mesure doit être
irréprochable et nous avons différentes
difficultés selon que l'on dépend de
1900 1950 1907 est incontestablement un
regard avisé à avoir pour ne pas
déséquilibrer les choses mais il
n'empêche quand même nous aurons besoin
d'un outil juridique qui nous permettent
d'agir efficacement la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement partage
une large part des mesures mais devront
donc être vigilants sur leur inscription
dans la loi car le pire serait de subir
la censure du conseil constitutionnel
très pointilleux sur la liberté
d'association et la liberté d'expression
comme le gouvernement en a déjà fait
l'amère expérience avec la loi via sur
la haine en ligne qui a été quasiment
intégralement retoquée par les sages de
la rue de montpensier et donc rendues
inopérantes
yaël brune pied levé tout d'abord gérald
darmanin parle d'une nouvelle forme
d'attentât
c'est un sujet que vous suivez bien sûr
qu'est ce qu'il ya de nouveau pour vous
avec l'événement de conflans sainte
honorine
ce qui est nouveau dans cet événement là
pour moi c'est le mode opératoire qui
est absolument abominable qui nous a
tous saisis il est absolument incroyable
qu'en france aujourd'hui en 2020 un
professeur puisse être décapité
cette technique à la violence est
absolument incommensurable il ya un
avant et un après pour vous oui à ce
titre là je trouve que on a on a franchi
une étape dans la dans la symbolique
dans la symbolique du professeur est
dans la symbolique de l'acte on
mais on voit bien et on voit bien que
c'est vraiment l'objet même du
terrorisme le terrorisme est là pour
vous terrorisée donc en france ces
dernières années on s'en est pris à des
enfants
on s'en est pris à des journalistes j'en
ai mais ils restent des moments de
bascule mais on découvre que toujours y
avoir une bascule supplémentaires
exactement mais on a en fait face à
une escalade et ont fait face aussi à un
terrorisme qui est le fait d'individus
isolés dont plus difficiles à repérer le
fait d'individus qui se radicalise très
vite alors qu'avant on pouvait avoir des
processus de radicalisation sur des
années donc plus facilement repérables
par nos services de renseignement donc
le phénomène se complexifie et il faut
que nous nous adaptons nous nous
adaptons vous avez rappelé moi je suis
leur enseignement de très près je suis
membre de la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
et on voit que nos services s'adapte nos
services évoluent ils se muscle il gagne
en expertise gagnant en moyens humains
en moyens financière moyens
technologiques et il faut que nous les
aidions parce que la menace évolue en il
faut que la réponse évoluer si pour
mieux y faire face et pourtant le risque
zéro n'existera jamais vous dites
faisons attention à ne pas laisser
penser aux français qu'une loi pourrait
changer les choses pourraient arriver un
risque zéro
complètement la loi elle est utile on
voit bien aujourd'hui quand le ministre
de l'intérieur organise des visites
domiciliaires c'est parce qu'on a voté
la loi de sécurité intérieure et lutte
contre le terrorisme quand on arrive à
fermer un lieu de culte c'est parce
qu'on a voté cette même loi qui le
permet donc la loi est utile mais elle
ne suffit pas on voit bien et c'est
comme ça l'humanité est ainsi fait que
depuis le premier crime de la bible de
cars et abel il y a toujours des crimes
pour autant la justice est là les cours
d'assises prononce des peines parfois à
perpétuité pour autant le crime continue
à exister donc le terrorisme
malheureusement existera toujours et
fort heureusement on a plus de succès
que des chèques
on a quand même et je éviter plus de
trente attentats depuis 2017
ça n'est pas rien c'est autant de
victimes que nous avons réussi à
épargner et ça c'est le succès de nos
services de nos forces de sécurité dans
leur ensemble de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui elle aussi est
confrontée au terrorisme il
et il faut également le saluer donc la
loi est indispensable elle n'est pas
suffisante il faut une action résolue
et puis après il faut cette prise de
conscience de toute la société parle
quand même de changement dans la loi
est-ce que vous réfléchissez bien un
délit de séparatisme et qu'est ce que ça
pourrait apporter
alors on réfléchit beaucoup de choses
j'allais vous dire puisque le président
de la république a annoncé cette fameuse
loi sur le séparatisme dont l'arrivée le
9 décembre présenté devant le conseil
des ministres
exactement et donc au parlement au début
de l'année 2000 21 donc cette loi elle
est là justement pour lutter
efficacement et efficacement et plus
fort contre le séparatisme l'a musclé il
a fait danger atteindra probablement là
musclé mais en même temps elle n'est pas
encore fini de rédiger donc elle est
encore en construction mais en tout cas
il faut évidemment tenir compte de ce
qui se passe encore une fois le loi le
droit il est mou il est là pour
accompagner la société lorsque on voit
ce type de dérives
donc il faudra bien sûr prévoir
peut-être plus sont en voie qu'on ferme
une école il faut voir éventuellement
quelles poursuites on peut avoir quand
l'école est clandestine pour pas que la
personne se réinstalle 200 mètres cubes
pour faire une autre journée des
associations par exemple
yaël brume privé le ministre de
l'intérieur entend 10 ou des
associations baraka city le ccf le
collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france mais on voit le droit est très
protecteur la la constitution consacre
la liberté d'association et ce qu'il
faut changer le droit est ce que ces
associations pour aller faire fermer ou
est ce que ledroit l'empêchera alors la
constitution elle est là pour préserver
nos droits et libertés c'est elle qui
les affirment parfois on entend on
brandit certaines valeurs il faut se
souvenir que c'est la constitution qui
les érige et c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui en est le gardien de
cela on ne peut pas se plaindre après le
conseil constitutionnel doit aussi tenir
compte de la réalité des dangers
auxquels on doit faire face mais il est
censuré continere exactement ma
proposition de loi pour une mesure de
sûreté pourra les terroristes qui
sortent de prison constitucion le
conseil constitutionnel a dit non la loi
via sur la laine la une en ligne
le conseil constitutionnel a dit non et
ce que là vous ne craignez pas que le
constituent le conseil constitutionnel
disent non à de nouvelles mesures
mais écoutez c'est dans ses danses et
ses fonctions maintenant
moi je vous avoue que on a pas compris
pourquoi notre notre loi sur les
sortants de prison étaient censurés on a
un danger que tout le monde point le
procureur national anti terroriste les
services de renseignement le ministre le
parlement et vous vous souvenez des
débats a adopté à une très large
majorité cette loi de des bancs de la
droite jusqu'aux bancs centriste cdh a
republic en marche et même à l'assemblée
nationale le parti socialiste et le
conseil constitutionnel considère que
notre loi n'est pas nécessaire ni
proportionnée j'avoue mon
incompréhension face à cette
appréciation on va continuer à parler un
petit peu de ce sujet puisqu'on va
terminer avec le plus de la semaine qui
est lui aussi très fortement lié à
l'attentât de conflans sainte honorine
[Musique]
effectivement on en a entendu parler les
réseaux sociaux qui sont pointés du
doigt dans l'engrenage qui a mené à
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur était
auditionné au sénat et coûter la
criminal fonds spécifique de mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui par la
diffusion d'informations personnelles
pourraient pourrait une fois des
réunions au sommet se tienne bon
pourrait être puni de trois ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
damende sur le fait de diffuser sur les
réseaux sociaux évidemment mais pas que
on voit bien que c'est le sujet donc
c'est par quelques moyens que ce soit
parce que peut-être que la technique et
voulurent encore plus vite que la loi de
la république
le pourrait tout ce qui pourrait par
quelques moyens que ce soit diffusé des
informations ou des propos dans le but
qu'il soit porté atteinte à son
intégrité physique et psychique
on parle d'un délit de mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui pour diffusion
d'informations personnelles est ce une
bonne idée ce que cela aurait changé les
choses
dans le cas de l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit c'est difficile vous savez de dire
ce qui est ce qu'on aurait pu faire ce
qu'on aurait dû faire six mois je crois
pas que ça aurait changé les choses
malheureusement on aimerait tant que la
loi que la création du droit permettent
d'éviter cela maintenant il faut voir
effectivement quel est le processus qui
a été à l'ouvragé dans cet attentat est
effectivement en tirer les conclusions
et si effectivement et on voit bien que
les réseaux sociaux n'y sont pas pour
rien et que par l'utilisation de ce
média il ya eu cet appel alors je tairai
pas au meurtre mais en tout cas un appel
à la haine contre ce professeur voulait
des faits spécialement les grand chose
ma nécessairement encore elle a
forcément le problème alors c'est un
problème mais est ce que c'est le seul
problème je ne crois pas et on le sait
tous
et ça serait tellement facile dans cette
voie cela plus tôt repéré dans le cas de
samuel pâtit le problème c'est aussi que
peut-être le danger a été sous-estimé
qu'il a pas une protection ensuite c'est
difficile encore une fois de réécrire
l'histoire il faut maintenant sur ce
sujet laissez-les enquête se faire
l'essai le procureur national anti
terrorisme l enquête
mais moi je trouve que la création de ce
délit est quelque chose d'extrêmement
intéressant je pense que il faut il
absolument regarder cela de près
et si ça peut éviter ce type d'attentât
ou si ça peut quand même appelé
certaines familles à ne pas s'exprimer
ainsi d'une façon complètement mais
délirante et intrusive
ce sera déjà une très bonne chose de
faite on voit est-ce qu'il faut créer un
nouveau délit on voit le gouvernement a
town la mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui
là on le voit dans la vidéo du parent
d'élève c'était une contestation il n'y
avait pas d'appel à la violence formelle
est ce qu'il faut un nouveau texte de
loi est ce qu'il faut forcément des lois
tout le temps des créations de nouveaux
délits après chaque fait divers aussi
horrible soit il va là encore une fois
on est quand même sur une inclusion dans
la loi séparatisme qui était prévu avant
ce fait divers donc on ne peut pas dire
qu'on est en réaction
maintenant on a ce projet de loi qui
vise clairement à réaffirmer les valeurs
de la république la laïcité à lutter
contre le séparatisme
donc si ce n'est que ce nouveau délit
peut s'intégrer et permettent de lutter
plus efficacement contre le séparatisme
il aura toute sa place bien évidemment
dans ce texte là il ya les brawn privé
lors de cette audition jean michel
blanquer air étaient également présents
et lors de cette audition il a incriminé
l'enseignement supérieur il a estimé qu
il y à des courants islamo gauchiste
très puissant dans ce secteur est-ce que
c'est pas mettre de l'huile sur le feu
que de dire cela
on m'a interrogé moi je ne commente pas
les propos des uns et des autres ce
n'est pas mon rôle moi je suis une
responsable politique mais le dit lors
d'une audition devant le parlement c'est
quand même il a choisi de le dire il a
choisi de le dire et c'est son droit et
c'est fort heureux maintenant moi c'est
pas ce ne sont pas les mots que
j'utilise
mais il faut mettre et je crois que en
cela je suis entièrement d'accord avec
jean michel blanquer
il faut mettre tout le monde devant ses
responsabilités ça suffit de considérer
que c'est la faute des uns ou des autres
concernant c'est problématique paradis
semences india de l'islamo gauchisme
il incrimine meti l'enseignement - tout
le monde est responsable je crois dans
la société
tout le monde est comptable de
l'évolution de notre société et chacun à
son niveau aux fonctions qui sont les
siennes doivent agir
jean michel blanquer à sa fonction de
ministre de la république et il le fait
formidablement bien
les syndicats étudiants également
doivent agir
les musulmans qui est on voit des
formidables recteur qui en ce moment se
dresse et ont des paroles extrêmement
forte et on a besoin de ces paroles les
politiques les journalistes chacun un
rôle
merci beaucoup il ya une bonne fille
mais je rappelle que vous êtes président
de la république en marge de la
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale merci tu as merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo d'ici
là très belle semaine sur les chaînes
parlementaires évident
[Musique]